سام نعود إلى ما أبلغنا عنه منذ
لحظات قليلة، وهو ادعاء الروس
بطريق بيلجا وهي المدينة الواقعة على
الحدود مع أوكرانيا والتي
أظهرناها على الخريطة عدة مرات
فوق الحدود من أوكرانيا، يقولون إن
هناك  المخربون الأوكرانيون الذين يعملون
في تلك المنطقة وما حولها، ماذا يمكنك أن
تخبرنا
جيدًا، الأوكرانيون يقولون نعم أنت على حق
باستثناء أنهم ليسوا أوكرانيين، إنهم
روس ويقولون بالفعل إن
الوحدة نفسها قد نشرت مقطع
فيديو يقول إنهم  متورطون في
هذه العملية عبر الحدود لأنهم
أعضاء في فيلق الحرية من
روسيا وهو عبارة عن مجموعة من
المتطوعين الروس الذين هم في
القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية الذين كانوا
يقاتلون في الماضي عندما واجهتهم
مرة أخرى في ديسمبر كانوا يقاتلون
بكثافة شديدة جنوب بارهاموت على
خط المواجهة هناك، يبدو الآن أنهم
عبروا إلى روسيا مع
فريق روسي بالكامل وفقًا
للأوكرانيين، وتقول الحكومة الأوكرانية
بشكل مخادع إلى حد ما إنهم
يعملون هناك بالكامل
كمواطنين روس كعملاء أحرار وليس  كجزء من
القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية على الرغم من أنهم
بالطبع يستخدمون الزي الرسمي الأوكراني ورصاص
الأسلحة ويمكن القول إن المركبات
الآن هم المتحدثون الرسميون أو
عضو جناحهم السياسي هنا في
أوكرانيا، وقد أخبر شبكة CNN أن القتال
مستمر ومن المؤكد أن وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ستفعل ذلك
تشير من خلال عدد من مقاطع الفيديو التي
يتم نشرها إلى أنهم انتشروا
في عدد من القرى
القريبة جدًا من الحدود. هذه هي
المرة الأولى التي نحصل فيها على تأكيد من
الأوكرانيين أنه على سبيل المثال
قامت منظمة عسكرية مدعومة من أوكرانيا بتنفيذ عمليات  أه
عمل عسكري علني ضد روسيا داخل
الأراضي الروسية رأينا في الماضي
عمليات عسكرية سرية في عمق
الخطوط الروسية هنا في أوكرانيا وبالفعل
أنشطة غامضة داخل روسيا
نفسها حتى أنها كانت
هجمات بطائرات الهليكوبتر الحربية قريبة من مدينة
بلغراد في  في الماضي
رفض الأوكرانيون الاعتراف بذلك
ولكن هذا هو أول جون، نعم سام، دعني
أشير إلى الخريطة هنا حتى
يتمكن الناس من رؤية أننا نستمر في الحديث عنه، هذا هو
طريق بيلجا هنا عبر
الحدود من أوكرانيا هناك و  في البداية،
كما لاحظت تأكيدًا أوليًا من الأوكرانيين على
أن
القوات الموالية لأوكرانيا على الأقل تعمل
داخل الأراضي الروسية، يعد سام كيلي
تطورًا مهمًا، وسنعود
إليك بعد قليل، شكرًا لك